powerful batch came here with the
intention of doing research on black
grouse hazel grouse and wood crafts
these shy birds live in the national
parks on both sides of the czech
bavarian border but it snowed hard over
night so pavel won't be able to find any
of the birds tracks these species are
disappearing from commercial woodland
but here in this forest they're doing
fine we want to find out how many of
these birds there are and where they're
located we feel a cilium on the two
national parks are working on a joint
project that will do exactly that
in fact both parks cooperate closely on
these kinds of efforts and no one
represents that spirit of cooperation
better than biologists powerful boetker
he works for both parks together the
parks make up the largest primeval
forest area in central europe humans
shaped the landscape for a long time now
it's nature again and that attracts
numerous visitors
the park agencies also cooperate on book
publications most are available with
texts in both German and Czech the man
responsible for this is powerful hooba
named the director of schumer VAR
national park body faced a lot of
opposition both national parks and both
directors are working toward the same
goal we want these parks to develop
together with the same conservation
policies and we both have similar ideas
on how to do that in appreciation of
this cooperation the European Union has
provided subsidies totaling more than 6
million euros over the last two years
that money is also welcomed by the
Bavarian National Park administration
director Hans libels says this kind of
cooperation shows that European nations
can work well together he explains why
the program works we talk to each other
a lot and we trust each other
we try to find things that we have in
common and then we put projects together
sometimes we just sit around in the
evening and discuss things over a beer
and forms of a pan under sits and look
at a room day by an draws beer and see
how stars you know much toasty we're
honest people and they tell it like it
is they don't pull any punches but our
discussions are always very pleasant
communication is good
a real Czech German winter fairy tale
but powerful bench cos says both sides
will have to work hard to make sure
things stay that way in the years to
come